okay so this is a video that i feel like
has been a long time in the making for
me if you guys don't know who i am my
name is agc jake uh you can just call me
jake if you want i've been playing
rocket league for six years coming up in
february this month when it released on
xbox back in 2016. and in those six
years i have accumulated about 7 600
hours playing the game no other game
that i've played has even come close to
the amount of time that i put into
rocket league i played casually until i
felt like i was good enough to maybe
join a team at some point that was
probably around the time i was rising
star back then probably a lot of you
don't even know that that used to be a
rank which is about the equivalent of
like a diamond player today maybe joined
a team actually from that team got way
better from that point on and i would
say the day that i decided to be a
professional at rocket league was the
day that the game just started going way
downhill for me because i will say
rocket league is one of the best
experiences that you can have in gaming
for the first
500 hours that you play it when i first
started playing rocket league it was the
best time i've ever had in gaming so
much fun when you're just getting going
and i can say from experience and i
think a lot of other people will agree
with me here maybe some won't that's
okay
uh but as you play the game more and get
better at the game
the game honestly gets a lot worse
there's a lot of reasons for that um
i'll get into those in this video from
my experience there's a lot of them that
don't necessarily have a ton to do with
the game itself the gameplay is
pretty good there's a lot of issues with
the servers there's a lot of issues with
not that many things to do in the game
and that the rank system in my opinion
is completely busted stupid and broken
we'll get into all that but just wanted
to let you know that i'm not making this
video because i freaking hate rocket
league i don't i don't hate the game i
think it's great i wouldn't play it as
much as i have and i wouldn't be making
this video
you know if i didn't care you know i
care about the game i love the game i
want to see it succeed i just don't
think it will and i hope i'm wrong to
all the people that i've met in the
rocky league community to all the
success i've gotten in the rocket league
community all the friends i've made all
the content creators out there that are
finding success in the pro players and
the esports scene i hope you find
success i truly truly do i want to see
it happen i personally just don't
believe it and that has to go into the
biggest reason
is that the community is
terrible you know recently we've seen a
lot of uh drama going on in the rocket
league community there's been probably
in the last year several instances the
the two instances that i can think of
was first the miss dirty bird thing who
she faked having cancer to get viewers
on twitch
literally can't think of a worse thing
to do but she did that and the other
instance more recently was everyone
getting involved in a relationship issue
between like hira a bunch of people i
don't even know so i didn't even care
that much but when i went on twitter
that day
it was all i saw because i'm a part of
the rocket league community twitter's
like here's a bunch of rocket league
stuff from a bunch of people i don't
follow
and it was just filled with absolute dog
[ __ ] drama
that
all i could think of was who cares this
has like nothing to do
with rocket league it has nothing to do
with with any of it it was like a
relationship issue and then yes there
was a thing where like this guy's like
30 years old 28 years old or something
this girl's like 18. that's kind of
weird i'm not gonna i'm not gonna cap on
that that's this is just odd i wouldn't
personally do that whatever man it it
just doesn't concern the entirety of the
rocket league community you know i just
think the rocky league community has a
hard time
uh not getting involved in random drama
honestly because they're bored i think
that's the biggest thing with rocket
league is that the more you play it the
more you get into it
it's boring you know you can only play
so much ranked without losing your
freaking mind uh nobody wants to play
casual unless you're a psychopath and
you know just like to to drive around
hey good for you you're not a psychopath
i don't know why i said that i don't
personally enjoy it i like being
competitive in my competitive online
multiplayer game which is what rocket
league should be and then casual is just
like there's a bunch of people that just
leave even though there's a forfeit
option now nobody tries nobody cares is
this it's just weird dude the extra
modes are fun i'll give it that but just
get rid of snow day i always hated snow
day i know there's like a small
community who's like snowy's the best
game of the game no it's not uh it's
stupid the puck doesn't work i'm not
gonna get too into that yeah you know
there's there's game modes but those
game modes have been there for years now
and again
we're getting bored i'm bored i don't
want to play it anymore it's it's not
fun i don't have fun playing the game
that i put 7 600 hours into i'm sure the
argument to that is dude you shouldn't
have played that much while i was trying
to be a pro i turned into a coach i made
it all of my content so it kind of makes
sense that i put that much time into it
but say whatever you want so to
summarize what i just said i think the
community is bored and how that ties
into the drama [ __ ] that we see on
twitter and then the community itself
is because they're bored there's nothing
else going on so the first sign of
something exciting happening
they're all into it they're like let's
beat this down to it to nothing and put
them in the dust and i don't know why
rocket league players do that why rocket
league community people do that it's so
odd it's happened so many times i can't
think of every instance
where you know the community just sees
this this issue and then they bash it
into the earth it kind of reminds me
when i'm playing ranked and somebody
makes one tiny mistake and you'll have
the one person in the lobby that just
completely stops playing gives up
they're down by one goal with four
minutes left and they think it's a total
wash that's kind of what it reminds me
of kind of all ties together in my
opinion and that likely has to do with
the community being extremely young and
there's nothing wrong with that it's a
video game especially on epic games
where fortnite kids came over to rocky
lee because they were bored of fortnite
and it was starting to get dog [ __ ] and
rocking he's like oh we're free to play
now in epic sick dude so what i mean is
the player base is young that's totally
fine
but why are they young and toxic there's
so many deep reasons that i could get
into that but
in my opinion young kids today don't
know how to compete
and they don't really know how to lose
without pitching a fit you know they
probably played like church soccer or
intramural soccer whatever and if they
kick the ball
of foot they'll give them a big ass
trophy and said great job good job good
job for trying johnny that's getting
that's getting way too deep into it i do
think it has something to do with like
all games with young player bases just
getting so terrible but that's like a
whole other thing that i wanna get into
i'm gonna i'm gonna stick with rocket
league here player base is young player
base is toxic it's just not an enjoyable
experience to play anymore at this point
for me and i think a lot of other people
as well a lot of my best friends that
played thousands of hours of rocket
league have just completely quit they
don't play it anymore they they don't
want to they don't want to look at it
they they're just done with it they're
done with all of the [ __ ] that comes
with it and the [ __ ] that comes with
it has a lot to do with how the game is
really hard rocket league is obnoxiously
hard and when you tell a player base
that you have to put thousands of hours
into the game to get to this particular
rank or whatever rank it is however much
time it takes it takes a lot of time to
get good guess what they do
they quit and according to this graph
that i'm going to put up on the screen
you can see when the game peaked is when
it went free to play and then everyone's
playing the game as it goes on and then
once they realized oh my god how much
time do i have to put into this game i
quit and then the the player base just
completely drops off back to below what
we were in 2017 that is absolutely
unacceptable and i personally tried to
make it so the game could be easier for
people so that they would stick around
and play the game i made a whole rocket
league school we had a discord filled
with 15 000 people that we had to delete
because it was so unbelievably
unmoderatable and toxic people just
spamming the same questions over and
over again like hey i'm stuck in champ
how many times can you answer that
question and just have nobody listen to
you it's unbelievable it's a big reason
i stopped coaching because eventually my
replay archive where i would have people
send over their replays so that i can
analyze them on stream it was always the
same thing i was just repeating myself
hundreds of times over again it's so
boring and i put these replay reviews on
youtube for people to watch and they did
not watch them you know only a few dozen
or a few hundred people would even give
it a watch or even have the attention
span to last two minutes into a replay
review and they'd go off and go play
ranked which is not the way to get
better at the game and i would have
students who would go off
play terrible come to me get a replay
review go off and play great and as soon
as they don't feel like they're playing
great anymore they come right back to me
and ask me the same questions they did
before what am i doing wrong what is
this stuff and i'd go back to it said
you're still doing this the same stuff
incorrect you just stop thinking of it
and you know what they tell me or they
know what they prove to me by what they
do
is they don't care they want the secret
sauce they want the mcdonald's big mac
sauce the chick-fil-a sauce
of the secret to rocket league and when
you tell these people these these kids
that it doesn't exist that there isn't
an exploit that they can do to get
immediately better at the game they quit
or
they just go off and play they don't
care and then they come back to you with
the same questions again either because
they didn't have the attention span to
actually pay attention to what you said
before or they legitimately just don't
remember they don't know how to do it
themselves it gets real old real quick
and i think a lot of other
freelance rocket league coaches out
there will tell you the exact same thing
you guys aren't gonna get the secret
sauce it doesn't exist in the game it's
not a thing
unfortunately i wish there was i wish i
could give you the secret sauce which by
the way is just practicing and not going
and just plain ranked for you know
losing 10 games a row one day and
winning 10 games in a row one day
you're gonna come back down to where you
belong
which is probably a plat diamond or
champ which is where i see all of these
players who are struggling is right in
that area the people before them are
just having a great time they're just
playing the game it's like oh this is
fun i got gold sick
plat one hits it's like they lose their
brain they lose their mind but going
back to my example of the game peaking
and then falling off because the game is
just too hard
i made freaking 20 000
in one month just from people subbing so
they could get a replay review from me
in one month after it went free to play
they all wanted the secret sauce to get
better i did my best to to give them the
workshops that they could use the
training packs they could use the
practice regimens that they could do and
they quit anyway it didn't matter i
think for one reason is that i am not
considered a professional player i have
a lot of time in the game i've reached
the top ranks of the game i've played in
rlcs myself it doesn't matter unless
they're hearing it from squishy muffins
they will not listen to it and honestly
if i'm being totally honest squishy
muffins does not give any reasonable
information to get better at the game
not really i'm not bashing squishy
muffins for anything honestly i
completely understand why you don't
answer these questions they get annoying
but i think this is the biggest reason
the game is not growing the best players
in the game are not giving useful
content or useful information to the
overall player base so that they'll want
to keep playing and keep trying almost
every time i go into the live stream of
one of these pro players they'll see a
question in chat and one they'll either
completely ignore it or two
they'll tell them to just go practice
nobody wants to hear that then again
these are the pro players they don't
have to answer this stuff they are
playing to compete they probably don't
even want these players to get better
they don't care that's completely
understandable this is just a big reason
why the game is not growing i think it
is completely unacceptable for rocket
league to be in the position that it is
currently in on twitching youtube the
numbers do not lie it is a low as ever
and unless rlcs is streaming which gets
hundreds of thousands of views the
esports scene is incredible and i think
it is in a great place but the main game
is so freaking boring to to watch
someone play ranked or do whatever on
their live stream sometimes i see it
struggle to get 10 000 views on twitch
which i think is completely unacceptable
i believe that rocket league should be
the biggest game on any platform youtube
twitch
twitter wherever it should be the
biggest game it is it's it's the best
esport out there people should be
flocking to it like the fact that league
of legends a game that i will never be
able to fully understand even like
watching it
it gets
so many more viewers than rocky i don't
get it but i guess that makes sense when
you watch rlcs is all these these
viewers come in they give it a look and
they're like oh this makes sense it's
soccer whereas you know all of the
league of legends players the main
player base gets it and that's where
where all of those average viewers no
matter what's playing lcs or just a
regular stream like tyler1 or something
they're providing something for the
viewer and that's why there's there's
there's viewership there on twitch
youtube wherever but right now rocket
league just doesn't have enough content
within it the main player base of the
game is not getting the help that it
needs to just keep playing the game
because it there's no other game like it
you can't go from
valorent to call of duty you know with
perfect aim there you can't go from
valorant to rocket league it doesn't
compute there's no other game like
rocket league out there that's why it's
so difficult nobody wants to get into it
it makes sense and then you tack on the
fact that the the community is so toxic
they're looking for drama they're
they're looking for any excuse to give
within a match that just creates
toxicity instead of building a community
together why the [ __ ] would anyone want
to play the game unless you're like me
or and a lot of other people out there
who put so much time in the game you
feel obligated to play it which is not
good so this last part that i'm going to
do is all about me if you don't care
about me you can just you can just the
video's over for you you can you can go
to another one when it when it comes to
me and rocket league i just i have a bad
relationship with the game man because i
feel obligated to play it because one of
how much time i put into it and two it's
the content that people want to see on
my channel i i blew up on twitch because
of how much viewage i was getting on
tick tock rocket league i mean i got 210
000 followers in like three months on
tick tock of course that means the only
thing people want to see from me is rock
league totally makes sense but when i
say it was destroyed in my mental health
like i literally wanted to go
commit scooter ankle many times in the
last few years because of rocket league
because of the community because of the
content i feel like i was
not forced to make but felt like i had
to to
to progress my career that's my own damn
fault man there is no other excuse other
than i kept putting myself into the game
and
that's my own fault you know when you
put so much time into something and so
much work and effort into trying to help
this community and help grow it and just
seeing all of this drama and and
toxicity that just funnels over what
you're trying to do full full force goes
way over what i'm trying to do is which
is to help the community just gets
trampled by toxicity and drama that just
kills me man it [ __ ] kills me because
the only thing that i want to see is
rocket league grow and get better and to
see the community come together and have
a good time and and start to love each
other again like it was when i first
started playing there was a time when
that existed where we were all together
helping each other making content that
made us all laugh and entertained that
isn't just plain ranked and answering
unmeaningful questions to get better and
questions that have already been
answered hundreds of times everywhere on
the internet so i hope you don't take
this video as i don't like the game
[ __ ] love it it's fantastic there's
no other game out there like it i think
even the people that quit the game will
agree with me on that it's it's
fantastic but the things that come with
it the more you play it just makes it
unplayable
thanks for watching